pour moi ce n'est pas un jeu c'est une
fête c'est un art et le public
à mon avis ne vient pas s'amuser à la
corrida il vient se divertir il vient
voir la mort parce que c'est le seul art
dans lequel la mort soit présente
réellement mais il suffit de venir dans
les arènes pour voir le public être
graves être solennel il est pas du tout
là haut contrairement à la légende il
est pas du tout là en berne dans train
de boire des bières et de rigoler j'ai
jamais vu j'ai dû voir des corridas
seulement moi ça fait un an que je
connais la corrida j'ai jamais vu de
gens s'amuser et au moment de la mise à
mort la mort du taureau de cet animal
qui est adoré vénéré par une partie du
peuple du sud
ce moment est grave ce moment à un poids
et je pense que ce les gens qui sont là
ont conscience de l'importance de la
mort de cet animal adoré contrairement à
tous les gens qui ont qui mangent de la
viande et qui n'en a rien à la
date de la manière dans dont l'animal
tué et d'ailleurs ce qui est intéressant
je sais pas si vous vous souvenez de 7,7
cette histoire il ya quelques années un
an ou deux un supermarché avait vendu
des gibiers en barquette
il y avait des lapins non dépecer des
lièvres nous dépecer en barquette savait
créer un scandale c'était un scandale et
la direction du supermarché s'était
excusé et avait retiré
c'est à dire parce qu'on voyait là parce
qu'on voyait l'animal et on avait
conscience de manger un animal mort on
voyait la mort on voyait qu'on avait tué
un animal
or dans la corrida évidemment la mort
est là elle est mise en scène elle est
acceptée on la regarde en face
[Musique]